25 richest americans paid no federal
taxes report the street
tesla's elon musk former new york mayors
michael bloomberg amazon's jeff bezos
the activist investor carl icahn
have all managed to pay zero income
taxes in at least one year in the past
15 years propublica reported a billion
investor george soros managed to pay no
income taxes
three years interest in one year bezos
paid no income taxes 2011.
he even climbed and received they even
claimed and received a 4 000
tax credit for his children according to
the report from 2006 to 2018
bezos saw his wealth increase 127
billion dollars over the period he
reported six and a half billion dollars
in income
on which he paid 1.4 billion dollars in
federal taxes when compared with his
uh with his overall gains that amounts
to one point one percent true tax rate
on the rise on his fortune uh top
topping uh propublica's list is
uh berkshire hathaway's warren buffett
the oracle of omaha reportedly
had income of 125 million from 2014 to
2018
pay 23.7 percent in taxes a true tax
rate of 0.1
the way they're doing the math right
okay so
this concept becomes and by the way
somebody leaked their taxes i don't know
somebody somebody from the irs which is
a federal offense by the way
anonymous anonymous and then you see the
the the press secretary's like oh we are
going to get to the bottom of this no
you're not
this is irs giving you the story right
before you're pitching the idea of
raising taxes is a good thing
and look at all these rich people let's
turn them into bad people so then
so let's do this here's here's the other
way of thinking about it
all these incentives first of all
money's free it's easy today to get
meaning for the rich it's very free
interest rates
are low it's so easy to go get 50 100
200 million dollars today
if you have money there's the saying
when you have money they don't lend you
any money
15 years 20 years ago nobody gave me a
loan out of bank i couldn't get a loan
at a bank if i tried
hell if i wanted to rent a car from
hertz they wouldn't give it to me
because
we're worried because your credit sucks
so bad right today everybody's just like
hey
you want another 10 million you want
another 40 million and 1.35 million you
want another 20 million
here you go it's just money being given
away right because it's cheap
how do we get here rates stay low like
this
it's going to keep happening the
separation on the wealth is going to be
taking place now on the flip side when
you hear these stories about how bad the
rich people are
okay let's look at our compensation plan
that we have with taxes
let's look at the compensation plan that
we have in taxes and let's
let's get rid of all the incentives of
people to become entrepreneurs
what does america look like without elon
musk let's take them out there is no
elon musk
or a elon musk top of a person in the
last 20 years okay
which is not like somebody to say well
if there's not an elamas there will be
another illamas no no
say there is no elon musk type of a
person in the last 20 years
say there's no jeff bezos type of a
person last 20 years
say there's no warren buffett type of a
person last fifty years
say there's no car like stops the whole
point i'm trying to make to all these
guys
what does america look like is it a
better place no is it is america
a better place without bezos musk
buffett all of these guys in my opinion
no it's not a better place without them
no so so what what causes these guys to
be willing to go work to work their
tails off put so much
risk anxiety fear worry at night sitting
there oh my gosh i'm working like elon
musk for 20 years i never took a day of
vacation
buff gates for 20 years i never took a
day of vacation
how many people are willing to do that
and there's a bunch of people that are
asking about a four-day work week these
guys work 20 years straight
the incentive is if i go 20 years
without working kind of like what scott
galloway said in his article yeah
he said i used to go on tuesday morning
and not come back to a wednesday night
you can work 30 hours straight
the incentive is how many people are
willing to do that at his age
not many anymore so if they do they
deserve the kind of wealth
that they're getting if you try to
punish them what happens next is what
the next 20 years you will not have an
elon musk
the next 20 years you will not have a
basis being inspired by that
that's the part that people forget go to
some of the biggest socialistic
countries in the world
and tell me what incredible products
were produced there go
go to the greatest biggest socialist
countries and you tell me what
technology
you use today that that came out of a
socialistic technology
what what technology well i don't know
what the hell they're doing in china but
they're doing something there but in
china
it's a different story in china china's
taking all the trade secrets from
america
and they're trying to control to make
china more powerful it's not innovation
that's
theft is what it's called but they set
it up in a way on contract where
american people who got the money
they said it's not a big deal let's give
it to them so it's not called theft they
did it legally but it is theft
it's a thing of that theft of ipa theft
of ideas without letting you compete in
their country so
they're not even denying it we'll take
facebook from you we'll take all this
stuff from you but you can't have that
in our country but we can have it in
your country brilliant idea that they
have anyways
this whole stuff with taxes and
influence let me ask you a question can
can there be two sides of this coin
meaning
i don't think it's right that you vilify
successful people like i don't think
that
uh anti-capitalist vilification of the
warren buffets of the world
and the bezos of the world and the most
of the world and all these guys who have
made a major influence steve jobs as you
mentioned
the vilification of these types of
entrepreneurs to me is is ridiculous
it's absurd but at the same time can you
also say
yeah maybe they should pay their fair
share like warren buffett has said
i'm willing to pay more taxes meaning
can you
congratulate them why not vilify though
no
let's not raise taxes but do it give a
billion dollars additional to taxes
go ahead just like charity go ahead a
lot of them have signed up for the
billionaire pledge
what i'm saying is if you're so noble of
a human
being where you say i'm willing to pay
more taxes why don't you
go ahead you can a lot of them if i may
answer this
a lot of them say i don't trust the
government to do no right you don't
neither don't either give it to me
neither do we then
don't don't give them don't give that
line when you're worth 100 billion
dollars just to look good in the story
while you kill the next buffet that's
coming up
you're talking buffett is the one who
said that no [ __ ] and i'm calling him
out yeah
don't say that after you made 100
billion dollars and you screwed up for
the next
17-year buffet that wants to come up
what the hell are you doing did you
forget when you were 17
you so you want to make it harder for
the next so you want to make the barrier
to entry
for the next buffet to come up you want
to make it harder for him that's what
you want to do
so that's your policy right there yeah
well i got my money already forget about
i'm about i'm 90 years old right now
yeah i'm this old wise guy now and don't
worry young guys you don't need to be as
wealthy as me
it's not as good who are you to make
that decision for me now that you have
the money it's easy for you to say it no
yeah let the young 14 year old buffet be
inspired to be more than you
so you're saying that buffett's speaking
out of both sides of his mouth and not
thinking about the
future generations look i asked the guy
one time i said
why why do some of these billionaires
who become so wealthy
why do they all of a sudden start
sympathizing and like oh my gosh all
this other stuff he says because they
feel bad they feel bad because of what
what do they feel bad about what the
only thing you ought to feel bad about
is
you know the documentary about vince
lombardi where they said at the end of
the days
lombardi wasn't a happiest guy when he
died there'd be parties he'd have drinks
and he'd step away and he would go cry
in his room by himself
and his wife would go to him and says
hey baby what's going on i don't know i
don't know he wouldn't he'd go and
cry hardcore right and they said this
just doesn't make sense why is lombardi
doing this
so when i interviewed the coach of the
chicago bears mike ditka
and i'm sitting at his barn in uh
the most boring his wife was sitting
right there when we did the interview
and i asked him about everything
kaepernick all this other stuff he says
you know what maybe i was wrong
fine maybe i was too hard maybe i was
too this i'm like dude that's not what i
want to hear
it's not what i want to hear because
what happens is
when you when you get older the energy
to argue certain
arguments for you it's just like i just
don't care anymore to do it right
so lombardi what is that background
noise by the way
who is it is it our guys can we just
tell them gerard ii
okay when you become older okay
and you get to a point where like
lombardi's going around he says finally
what would hurt lombardi was the fact
that he felt at the tail end of his
career was too tough on his players
he felt like he was too tough on his
players now when they interview the
players
can somebody step over there and just
have that conversation with gerard the
guy's so loud the whole country can hear
him right now
all right so he was so tough on his
players so they interviewed the players
and they said how do you feel about it
he says i disagree
because i wanted somebody like that in
my life
i wanted somebody that challenged me
that we did he says i never had anybody
that had such high expectations of me
says don't get me wrong he was very
tough
but i liked the way he was there was a
story about one wonder who was this
quarterback that played for him
uh bart starr bart star he says bart
star one day
lombardi's berating him in front of his
players
you can't even throw [ __ ] what the hell
is going on with you
he just trashed him in front of his
players bart says
coach can i talk to you yeah he comes in
he says hey coach
why can't you if you want me to lead my
players
please don't undermine me in front of my
players can you do to me privately
he says he never did it ever again bar
star said that he says because i just
want to have the conversation with him
right
as people age and it gets i don't know
what it is to be 90 years old
and to be closer to heaven or to be
closer to
you know whatever age of 20 30 to relate
to that
as you get older you become disconnected
with the younger ah you forget who you
were at 15 sure
bro there's this book on lincoln called
lincoln on leadership
and one of the things he talks about is
circulate amongst your troops
the moment you no longer relate
to the minimum wage person and you
forget who you were
you know that whole song by jennifer
lopez which is what don't be fooled by
the rocks that i got i'm still i'm still
jenny from the block i used to have a
little now i have a lot no matter where
i go
remember by the way to me the only
reason that's my favorite jayla song is
because the words i don't know i don't
listen to jayla
the point is the point is buffett forgot
when he was just
warren from the block he forgot yeah he
did he said a rough
don't be fooled by the stocks that i got
yeah and i think part of it is that
negative guy underneath him charlie
you know his hunger you know he's about
as bitter as you can possibly get
you know in regards to the the the tax
that the rich are paying
no one's accusing them of breaking any
laws and if if you
have that type of wealth you have people
that are smart enough to stay one step
ahead of the tax code and the irs and to
figure it all out
which makes me think they'll just figure
out the next thing too right they always
do yeah and by the way
adam said there's nothing we can do
about it actually we can when it comes
to inflation we can vote out the people
that are in power when inflation hits
and that usually does happen
dude by the way this guy in motown music
factory i don't know who it is because
there's not a name behind it just gave
10 bucks and he said america will look
worse
than detroit without people like elon
musk
just ask jack ma i agree and i'm going
to give you ten times what you gave us
which is a hundred dollars
let's make a note kai the motown music
factory send us a text three one zero
three four zero one one three two we're
about to send you a hundred dollars
because i agree with you as well we have
to recognize these people and build them
up
we're trashing innovators right now
we're destroying
innovators right now everything is about
you know the
the people today there is a business
model
on youtube for just trashing others
constantly
we enjoy that people are enjoying seeing
it right it is a model that happens
i posted a picture of the house i bought
right because
barons did a story on it and then uh a
real
real deal did a story on it a bunch of
people did a story on it and so finally
uh my guy says what do you want to do i
said tom why don't we write them put the
pictures up so tom wrote the story on
uh uh vpos.com hey you know
uh uh what do you call it uh bought this
house and for
north fort lauderdale record break and
whatever 20.4 million auto house i
bought right last week and i got the
keys and i flew out right the moment i
got the keys but i slept in it two times
this year
three times this weekend taking a shower
the other day
and thank god it's covered here on the
bottom but at top it's not
taking a shot and i'm looking around at
the top is open so when it rains you see
the rain
and i'm looking like oh my gosh from a
freaking apartment complex in granada
hills where drive-bys were taking place
too
who the hell would believe this story if
i told you in high school one day pat
hey
if somebody said pat one day at 42 years
old they're going to limit this kind of
house
say what the hell are you on right now
the drugs are using that's the american
dream
but you know what there was a lot of
messages that came but there was a lot
of messages that came with send me money
there's a lot of messages that came that
you know you could have given that money
to this there was a lot
everybody has their own dream to some
people the dream is
a different dream to some people it's
relationship to some people it's a house
to some people is
something big they want some people is
their legacy of their you know they want
to do something with big with it
thank god for the ambitious people who
have big dreams
and they try to do it the right way
they're going to break rules there's no
way in the world you're going to be big
without breaking the rules
but they don't break the laws but you
can break the rules you have to break
the rules sometimes to do something big
with it
thank god for them sometimes we just
have to sit there and be grateful
the fact that we had a chance to witness
a michael play when people tell me
i was looking at art in wynwood i was in
woodward two days ago
and i go to this one art store the guy
sees me he's like
oh [ __ ] i'm like what the hell i'm with
the
uh senna and anyways we're senna mario i
think we're out there
and uh carol so we go he goes to the
back hey hey come here
say hey i'm al this is cal and this is
val
cool good to meet you guys this is sad
we watch all your interviews
oh you watch the business interviews no
just the mob interviews
okay so you're the mob audience right so
we're sitting there we're talking
and uh uh what was i what story was i
telling right now is it talking about
the fact that um
your house your arts haters how's the
art the haters
oh man huh different dreams what was it
man i was about to tell a good story
what happened
the art yeah i forgot what the story was
but it had to do with that place because
i was looking at an art with this guy
and it was sort of coming in
in wynwood i don't know where i was
going with this but uh
the house start what was it where was i
going with this i'll get i'll get with
it here in a minute okay but get
mentally
back into that shower yeah get back
there you're feeling good
you were talking about everybody has a
different type of goal and it
might be a house for somebody yeah i i
just think we forget that man i think we
forget the little
kid that has a dream that wants to do
something big
and rather than go forget about the 50
year old elon musk i don't know how old
elon musk is i'm assuming he's in his
mid 40s too late yeah
mid 50s i think he's 49 on the fantastic
right now dude
go look at elon musk not as 49.
take a look at elon musk as a 12 year
old kid who kept
reading those books and imaginations and
people call them weird
who had an imaginary friend you know who
had all those weird things that he did
and he had a dream dude
don't look at him as that 50 year old
guy look at him as the
by the way even biden you know what i
look at with biden i don't look at biden
as
who he is today i look at bite i'm like
this guy probably when he was coming up
he was like he had a dream one day he's
going to be a
a president right the guy's got the
ultimate like the lowest underdog like
you know who he is he's like when the
florida marlins won the world series
that's joe biden if you think about that
team yeah it's like you know
jay buener you know pudge rodriguez guys
the great pictures randy was there i
think i think randy was there i don't
know who their picture was they had a
good picture there
but the point is we forget those stories
as much as you may disagree with
someone's
ideas trump at one point had the
pressure of the father
boarding you know they're sending them
away go at this place figure out your
life the resentment if you love me so
much why do you send me to a boarding
house
guy becomes a billionaire becomes a
presidential i mean
dude you got to plot some of these guys
so the world wouldn't be the same
without these people
we demonize them way too much yeah and
the media's grabbing hold of this social
warfare this class warfare and they're
running with it and it's
it's dangerous you know it's making
these people seem like they're evil or
that they should feel guilty about
making all this money
how about elon musk when he almost lost
tesla i mean he was working 20 to 22
hours a day trying to save it
so there's that too so yeah that's true
by the way this doesn't mean
you know everything with taxes to me is
a sales company's compensation structure
what incentives do you want
create a sales structure compensation
structure based on that
hopefully they'll do something about it
all i know is right now they're trying
to
drive it in a way to demonize rich
people and i don't think it's going to
work and work out for them long term
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye